la machine avale les pieds de tournesol
à un rythme soutenu l’élianthus la fleur
du soleil a bien profité cette année sur
cette parcelle de l'eau au moment des
semis d'avril et beaucoup
d'ensoleillement ensuite résultat un
rendement satisfaisant dans ces terres
profondes de la petite pause du
Loir-et-Cher on s'attend à un rendement
exceptionnel comparé à l'année dernière
mais bon ça ça devrait être autour des
30 quintaux quand même donc voilà cette
année on est plus sur une marge plus qui
est intéressante
c'est bon l'huile 2022 de tournesol est
plutôt bonne reste à connaître le
rendement en huile des graines récoltées
ici on vend l'huile de tournesol sur
place mais aussi en restauration ou même
en grande distribution la chute de
production en Ukraine a créé une demande
massive c'est la raison pour laquelle le
pressage a été largement anticipé cet
été le tas de tournesol que j'ai stocké
avant-hier il est vendu c'est garanti il
est vendu en temps normal je ne
transforme la récolte de l'année que à
l'hiver suivant
pour autant la récolte de tournesols ne
sera pas synonyme de jackpot pour tous
les agriculteurs les charges d'engrais
ou d'énergie ont explosé et ce bon
résultat permettra simplement de
redonner un peu de trésorerie aux
exploitations